Environmental Protection Agency
inspectors helicopter into a remote
National Park in the Amazon state of
parach where thousands of heads of
cattle have been raised illegally
they're now being confiscated but it's
too late for the rainforest which has
already been cleared
in the Yanomami indigenous reserve a
joint government task force sweeps in to
destroy illegal mining assets while in
the city of Benin inspectors check out a
lumberyard's Timber to ensure it comes
from a legal Source before being shipped
to England next week Alexa de Sousa
heads the environmental agency Obama in
the state of para which is the size of
Angola he says that under former
president Jade bolsonaro illegal cattle
farmers and loggers operated freely
in the previous four years we faced the
opposition of the president himself he
joined social networks that criminals
took part in to say that Obama couldn't
police them our agents were attacked and
received death threats
but the tide has shifted Environmental
Protection agencies are receiving more
financial and political support from the
new government and it's making a
difference
satellite data shows a decrease of
nearly 60 percent in deforestation
compared to the same period last year
it's the lowest drop in six years but
still much higher than between 2008 and
2017.
look this is where they've been starting
to Mark the area their Eau Claire this
was in May and a month later in June all
the trees you see in the pink area have
been removed that's equivalent to 750
Maracana football stadiums Brazil's new
left-wing government says it's committed
to combating climate change and
reversing deforestation in the Amazon
but it's easier said than done
Brazil's Congress is controlled by the
conservative opposition in fact the
lower house has already passed a bill
that would open up protected areas to
commercial interests such as oil Mining
and logging should the senate pass that
bill as well then president Lula da
Silva's promised to reach zero
deforestation by the end of this decade
would be a moot point
there's Fierce pressure from powerful
sectors in the economy as well as some
local communities to Fast Track
investment and development in the Amazon
the issue is finding ways to do so
without destroying it
to see a Newman Al Jazeera Berlin
foreign